what type of account do you recommend
for baby step ones emergency fund
William says on Twitter you can follow
me there at Dave Ramsey and anytime
you'd like the you know baby step 1 is
$1,000 save William it really doesn't
matter what kind of country put it in
it's not going to make any money if
there's no such thing as a 10% account
on a thousand dollars I mean it's you
can put in a money market if you want
and you're going to make 1 percent and
so we're talking about 10 dollars a year
so I don't care if you even put it in
the account as my point I don't care if
you keep it the sock drawer I just want
you to have a thousand dollars set aside
that you don't touch for anything now if
you want to put it in an account it'd
just be a little money market type
account at your local bank or you can
get to it if you have an emergency the
downside of keeping it on the sock
drawer is you might think the pizza man
at the front door is an emergency and
he's not so you need to be careful about
how you define emergency this is just to
be used for emergencies one lady took
hers and put it into a frame she bought
a cheap frame down at Walmart and wrote
under the road across the bottom of the
frame in case of emergency break glass
and then hung the thousand dollars
behind her coats and her closets because
I mean you're not going to make any
money on it William I mean it's just
it's there just to be used only for
emergencies only for emergencies that's
all it's for and you know your little
thousand dollar account hopefully now
when you grow the account up and baby
step three to a full three to six months
of expenses then I'm going to keep it in
the money market account even at that
point you're not making any money let's
say you've got fifteen thousand dollars
in there one percent it's a hundred and
fifty bucks I mean it's no money at all
you're not making any money on this
account so the emergency fund is not
about making money it's insurance to
keep you from cashing out or going into
debt cashing out stuff you shouldn't
have to cash out and so insurance
doesn't make you money insurance cost
you money to protect things that make
you money and that's the best way to
look at your emergency fund it's not an
investment it's insurance and that help
if you do it that way so I you know when
I had when I finally got a thousand
dollars and then I finally got ten
thousand dollars and and it was all I
had I was all concerned that it needed
to work really hard and you know I
started realizing that it's not going to
work hard when it's in an emergency fund
and so then I want to start investing my
emergency fund well that's a dumb idea
because by definition an emergency fund
needs to be easy to access what we
financial people call liquid and so you
have to set that aside
you just set this money aside and say it
is not for it's not the money that's
going to make me money it's the money
that's going to protect the stuff that
makes me money I don't have to I can you
know when you've got a big emergency
fund you can carry a higher deductible
on your insurance which causes you what
have lower premiums when you've got a
bigger emergency fund you know you don't
have to tap out your 401k or borrow on
your 401k if your car's transmission
goes out and so you get to leave alone
the things that are making you money and
you get to increase your decrease some
of your costs like insurance and those
kinds of things you know buy insurance
on everything that turns around because
you've got fifteen or twenty thousand
dollars set aside for your rainy day
fund one lady called it her Gok fund my
god only knows fund and I don't care
what you call it but that's how you do
it so good question William I appreciate
you bringing that up so baby step 1 is
$1,000 saved 2 is pay off all your debts
except your home using the debt snowball
where you list your debts smallest to
largest and pay them off in that order
with great focused intensity once you're
out of debt then you go accept your home
then you go back to the $1,000 account
in baby step 3 and raise it up to a
fully funded emergency fund of 3 to 6
months of expenses you need to run like
your hair's on fire until you get those
3 steps done you need to be in a panic
until you get those 3 steps done because
if you have $15,000 or $10,000 or
whatever 3 to 6 months of expenses in
your life represents
in cash in the bank and you don't have
any payments but a house payment just
think about your life right now how
would that feel no payments but a house
payment in fifteen or twenty thousand or
ten thousand dollars laying there you're
not even there yet
and you just started breathing better
just thinking about it
you took a deep breath and a sigh it's
exactly what you did after I said that
when you don't have any payments but a
house payment and you have your
emergency fund
that's a foundational place to begin to
build wealth
that's a foundational place to begin to
your level of outrageous generosity but
until you get there you're just
scrapping and clawing like a rat in a
wheel man and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind if people aren't making fun of you
you're probably not on track because
people are stupid people are broke they
said and I heard is the dumbest
financial planning firm out there
because if you look around seventy
percent of Americans are living paycheck
to paycheck one point four trillion
dollars in stupid student loan debt
another trillion is stupid credit card
debt car fleeces 78% of the cars that
leave a new car lot are fleeced right
now and most of the rest of them are
financed stupid is on parade all around
you it's a clown show financially you
want to be that I don't want to be that
that's where that's where when I hit
bottom I mean I didn't hit bottom
I completely splatted because I was
stupid with steroids men I know what
stupid looks like I looked up boy in the
mirror I know who he is he was wrapped
around my neck
so you don't want to live like that but
your foundational stuff is to at least
get rid of your debt not counting your
home and at least get you a rainy day
fund and you don't need to be doing any
investing until you get that crap
straight now it's time to put on your
big-boy pants your big-girl pants this
is grown-up talk here you're not in
Congress you have to live on less than
you make you have to apply yourself to
these situations you have to look in the
mirror and look at each other as a
married couple or as a single look in
the mirror and say no we're not going on
vacation we're broke we have two car
payments and a credit card loan a credit
card debt and a student loan that's been
around so long we think it's a pet no
we're not going out to eat we're not
going to strut around acting like we're
something we're not
Tom Stanley who wrote the book
Millionaire Next Door his last book
erode before he was killed in a car
accident a couple of years ago was stop
acting rich it was the title of the book
is a great title
stop acting rich that's what it comes
down to quit acting like you're
something you're not you don't have any
stinking money act like a broke person
why it's easy you're a broke person you
make sixty or ninety or 160 a year and
you got nothing nothing no money
payments coming out your ears out of
control strutting around acting like
you're something in Texas they call that
big hat no cattle stop it it's time to
lay these basic steps out and lay into
them and say that's it I'm tired of
being broke I work two stinking hard to
be this broke I put up a too much crap
to be this broke and anybody gonna fix
it in this election cycle
the only people's going to fix it's in
your house the White House isn't gonna
do nothing it's your house it's got to
do it people in your house got to start
behaving and then you can turn your
money around but it's an act it's a it's
an act of adulthood adults devise a plan
and follow it children do what feels
good this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you are not a victim you're not a victim
of big corporations you're not a victim
of Wall Street you're not a victim of
capitalism you're not a victim of wealth
inequality you're not a victim of racism
you're not a victim